it's a level of immersion that we really
focus on that you're not just playing a
game but you're living in this in this
world in this universe
it's a
giant open world for the player to do
what they want
you feel like you've had an impact in
the world you really feel like you're
there there's certain you know types of
entertainment where you're just
experiencing it you're taking in what
the creator wants you to see and that
you know they draw that dotted line
between this happens go here do this the
more that we can put you
in the situation where you're going to
decide that's what makes video games the
best form of entertainment that they are
[Music]
we don't just make rpgs like we make
simulations and that leads to a lot of
just crazy stuff that can happen and
things you don't expect yeah we always
have those big fights like what if
combat breaks out right now right you
have to handle that right because it
could you can't control it the only
thing you control is that the game has
to account for it somehow we embrace the
chaos let it play out and usually it's
pretty fun a lot of us been doing this
for a long time together and it's nice
with starfield to go back
to some things we didn't do the
backgrounds the traits the defining your
character all of those stats
and i think there's so many games now
that do those things that people are
ready for something that that does a lot
of the things that you know
older hardcore rpgs some that we used to
do doing those again in a new way we've
always allowed the player to
you know to create really interesting
unique characters this game we've
definitely severely leveled up the tech
is based on
scanning of real world models similar to
the photogrammetry we do in our
landscapes we're kind of applying the
same thing to our to our people as well
because it's not just the appearance of
your player and all that but you know we
want all the personal
interactions npcs other characters in
the game to be as impactful as possible
and for that you have to believe these
are real people you're a real person
interacting with real people
one of the big choices is which part of
the game world am i going to engage in
we always
make a bunch of different groups that
represent some of the major factions in
every game and in this one we've got the
united colonies that represents the
future space republic idealized you also
have the free start collective which is
the space western fantasy people that
are out there on the frontier
we've got reagent industries which
represents corporate life i think it has
one of the best starts
of of any of the factions yeah it's it's
a mega corps you have to you get hired
right like yeah or do right we'll play
for our job or see if you cut the
mustard right yeah i love approaching it
that way where okay what makes the world
feel whole what are the groups that
would make it feel whole and believable
and then how does the player interact
with them
you know what we're doing with the the
pirates the crimson fleet as well
they're not just this foe let the player
join them what does that mean the cool
thing about crimson fleet you know what
if you're a good person and you want to
be a good player and you don't want to
play as a bad guy you can side with the
pirates or you can report back your
superiors
and be like basically space cop type of
thing so let you be a good person and
still play with the bad guys i think
that's really cool too it seems like no
matter what story we write the one the
players tell themselves
is the one that they
think about and love the most and the
companions
[Music]
hello captain
how may i be of assistance
so something we really you know leaned
into
on this game how those other characters
felt about you
that's probably my favorite part like
when you're exploring and your companion
makes some comment off the cuff about
something that you're checking out or
something that just happened
it just feels so perfect for immersion
it's so believable you think it's it's a
real person so you know we knew we
wanted to do some kind of persuasion
minigame thing
yeah we sat down and it was funny we
didn't start with let's do an evolution
of let's look back at the old oblivion
system but there are a couple of beats
there you have to think about what's my
risk here
right which one do i want to choose we
didn't want it to be a system where
there was definitely the right thing to
say it feels like you're having a
conversation where you're actually
trying to persuade somebody of something
um so it's actually i think it's as far
as new systems
in dialogue i think it's it's definitely
one of the most successful ones that
we've had yeah i think when we knew we
were making a game about space you ask
yourself certain questions and that
question is what is out there and so as
a game we have bromance adventure
mystery but i think with starfield
there's this other layer of
you know the cosmos and the universe and
what is out there at the end of it we
want the players to
have told their own journey
but then
look back at it
and
we're asking the big questions
why are we all here where is it leading
and what's next for humanity
[Music]
you